that moment where john terry slips over
can you remember where you were standing
and what it felt like in that exact
second
yeah brilliant yeah it was but then then
you
you're almost your emotions are up and
down you almost celebrate
him i didn't care he was meeting my
teammate
at all i was buzzing he missed him but
then when edmund saved the penalty off
of nalco
for the next few minutes
you're just running around and
celebrating it
[Music]
i always remember alan stubbs at everton
he um
i was in this way coming to the squad at
16 and disturbed you must be about 33 34
i'd imagine
make sure you enjoy it because it goes
quick
and i remember thinking yeah because
you're your 30s
mid 30s um you would say that but
it acts it's actually through it does go
really quick it goes quicker than you
think and
um
i found myself now giving that same
advice to to younger players um because
sometimes in football you get caught up
in
a bin you'll actually lose
you lose sense of
of enjoying as much as you should do
because you the pressure of playing and
winning
and sometimes you forget to actually
enjoy it when was the time you enjoyed
football east was there a period like
where you were like i'm just not loving
this
when you lose yeah no i think
you're not no it's not that you don't
enjoy it but you're actually
because of the pressure say for instance
at manchester united the pressure to
to win trophies or win every game
um
means that sometimes you actually you
don't enjoy the game as much but when
you look back there you think oh
i play well we play well but
your mindset is just to win the game and
so you you actually don't enjoy it as
much when you're actually on the pitch
did anyone ever get onto you about your
discipline like did any senior pros ever
tell you to keep your head in the game
quite a few yeah
i always remember the one i used to get
frustrated with him
called rest him is ray clements
and before every england game so i'm i'm
getting myself worked off the game you
used to come up to me at the start of
the game and give me a big handshake
and say keep your head don't go don't
get bogged i'm just thinking don't don't
say that to me again before every game
because i used to
not used to actually wire me up so i'd
normally go out and get a yellow card or
go and boot someone quite early on
i'd probably say the moment which made
me happiest was
i was actually sat at home
um
watching chelsea of arsenal
and that was my first premier league we
played man city
the day before if chelsea didn't beat
arsenal we'd won the league so i sat
around watching it um
and then chelsea got i can't remember
his name the dutch guy centre-back got
sent off for chelsea and arsenal went
one night
so as the game was going on i remember
getting my jeans out in the off getting
them ready to go out until we've done
chelsea squad late on so you do the game
but we won the league so i just
remembered
then at the time all the players texting
each other um organizing where we're
going to go meet up and go out so
that was a surreal moment to win me
first premier league title the group
chat must have been absolutely popping
off it went group chat it was it
blackberries
and bbm yeah it was that yeah it's
always texted all different players but
then we all met up and went out and had
a good night you won so much across your
career but when you win something like
that is it just like a massive
celebration it depends yeah um
so this one we all met we went to the
room and
the others roped off here then all the
fans come in so there's loads of fans in
there as well so that was really good
actually to celebrate with the fans but
then there's other times when i won my
first trophy actually we won the league
club
and it was my first senior trophy
as a player obviously and
um i remember be it was in the
millennium stadium wales so getting the
plane home so i'm thinking like where
are we going
and everyone went home so i ended up
back home getting the chinese takeaway
just thinking i've never envisioned
him this is my first trophy sitting
around with a chinese takeaway
[Music]
yeah i think first was the longest day
ever i think we kicked off at about 11
00 p.m
she got a lot of time in the hotel and
to kill and relax and then we got to the
stadium
what did you do to relax i watched
sister act sister act
i watched that in the afternoon yeah i
don't really sleep in the afternoon
before the night game
and so watch this tractor got ready he
went off ready for the game
he went to the stadium
got changed got ready warm up and then
the game kicked off
the weather was horrendous him
the kit was really heavy went one a lot
they obviously scored equalized then i
went off
in extra time
and that was that was just as long
watching that last 15 minutes of next
time
and penalties than the rest of the day
really and
watching the penalties knowing you can
have no influence it was horrible and
and then
john terry stepped up and i've seen jt
take penalties for england and in
training
he's a really good pound taker and i
don't think i've ever seen a miss
and then thankfully he slipped and he
hit the post and
we got on to winner so um that was a
unbelievable moment that moment where
john terry slips over can you remember
where you were standing and what it felt
like in that exact second
yeah brilliant but then then you
you're almost your emotions are up and
down you almost celebrate
him i didn't care he was meeting my
teammates
at all i was buzzing he missed and um
you celebrate then you realize you've
got to score the next penalty
if so your emotions are up and down but
then when edmund saved the penalty off
of nalco
for the next few minutes
you're just running around and
celebrating it i remember actually um
i was still on the pitch i was looking
for clean in the crowd and
parents
and the members stood there and i had a
skull saxon next accent next to me and
he said all right lady
colleen's him up there she's over there
i was thinking who's this so turn around
it's aladdin from liverpool
he's got a photographer's outfit on so
he's
he's um he's got on the pitch and then
later on that night we've gone into the
party in russia the security was maximum
security and
um he's in there as a waiter
so he's he i think he had a good night
as well yeah
there's a few i mean there's
there's the red card against portugal
which
um i still haven't been honest i don't
know if i've met her or not i think it's
just something which happened my mind
can blank
um i don't know if i've tried to stamp
on them or if i've just
aimed done it accidentally i couldn't
tell you that when that happens and and
you get sent off and you have to like
walk past the dog out what what does
that feel like
right
now i was um
i remember walking in frustrated through
sight of the referee frustrated with
myself just with everything really
and then being in the dressing room just
thinking if we go through and miss the
semi-final final if we get to the final
if we go out it's my fault so it's a
no-win situation for me so that was
tough that was a tough moment it was a
hard one to actually
sit there and digest and digest them
and then like when the squad come back
in after being um knocked out on
penalties does someone come and talk to
you like what happened next
no if all the players come in then
i stood up and apologized to everyone
um because i felt it was right even
though
sometimes in football red cards happened
that's part of the game but um
it was such a big moment for everyone a
big welcome for everyone and
i thought we we were doing well in the
tournament and
i feel ever if i stayed on the pitch we
would have won the game um
so i just felt it was right for me to
apologize because i had him i had let it
let everyone down everyone knows you you
haven't done it too purposely to
to damage everyone else's chances in the
world but these moments happen it's
happened many times happened with david
beckham in in 98
it's happened with
players since all with him
unfortunately that's part of the game
which
um
you don't like to see happen to it to
many players after that world cup the
spotlight was on you and cristiano like
massively and how did you both deal with
that
well we went and won the premier league
so no listen i spoke to i spoke to
christiane on
in the tunnel after the game after i got
sent off
and
immediately after we'd been knocked out
and i'd apologize to players my
focus fully turned on manchester united
um against all um
i had sent someone into partial session
to bring cristiano out i think he might
have been thinking what's gonna happen
here
and but then i said to him listen
him good luck for the rest of the
tournament um
when you when the tournament hands for
you
um
all the press are going to be up at me
you're going to beat you in we need to
make sure we're focused to do our best
for manchester united that was it
tell us
yeah dwight evans just loved the way
our connection um
the two of us up front and
we complemented each other really well
because normally
a lot of if i played with louis sahar or
van nistelrooy in
van persie
these strikers were always the number
nine now players are number 10 or a bit
deeper but with tevas we could rotate so
i'd be done
and then he'd take the 9th while i'd be
10 and we'd rotate but then when we lose
the ball we'd should be running around
like two people started to get it back
so
um he was the one really as a strike
planner i enjoyed playing with most and
then when you see him join man say your
nearest rivals how did that feel
devastating
yeah i just because i enjoyed playing
with them that much and i could i knew
something was going on because there was
the issue with um his ownership in in
terms of who owned them whether it was a
club whether it was agent
um and it was actually very cheap to buy
him
and
for whatever reason we didn't we didn't
buy anything man city got him for about
20 million which
is incredible rallying and
you see him what a good player and great
player he is when he went there so yeah
i was devastated
[Music]
the
faq final in 2005
in stars yeah i'm in airplane two and
that was that was a painful day yeah we
absolutely batted them and we went to
quick time lost on penalties and
that was a tough one
after a loss like that how did alex
ferguson
come in and pick the team up like how do
you get the team going again next season
it makes you more determined i think um
it makes you
want it even more
in some way the
you've known you're so close um
and then
and that's what i'm saying about the
reaction you you rarely see the
characters of players and and the
character of a person
when you you you have such a
a defeat which hates so much
you can get over and come back from that
and some place didn't come back from me
and from nutty feet
but you see the real characters in the
team who who actually get you through
that um like we touched on on sir alex
there and he's famous obviously for
losing his temper and being a bit of a
spiky character um what was the biggest
argument that you two had
well we actually had
i'd say almost every game a half time
almost every game yeah
peter's a picture how did that happen
no it's just
you see the way the game was was going
he'd have a goal and he'd have a goal
with me um
if nanny or cristiano was was dribbling
along losing the ball he come in at half
time and i never got me for dribbling
and he knew that would get me
fired i'm looking thinking
you joking here i've got these two
dribbling constantly losing the ball and
you're having to go with me and then
i'll go back to him and
he but he knew that i'd get a good
reaction out of me and that was his way
of saying to to these whom stopped him
in the bomb because if he said to these
through the there'd probably be tears
yeah and he enjoyed it he knew what he
was doing he knew exactly what he was
doing he enjoyed i was having a go back
and
because he knew that i'd get fire the
rest of the players up for
he knew i played on him
on the edge especially at that time
him and he knew that get me going
[Music]
the best leader i'd say
it depends everyone's different so i
didn't play that long with roy keane
then we have villages captain um
guy neville's captain i don't know
there's there was so many different
leaders in that team i think stephen was
really good uh england
just determined quiet but
a lot of determination you could see
what it meant to him guy neville was
good very good boy frustrating as well
because a lot of the stuff he does
frustrate me but he was a good leader
can you give us an example just talks
too much him basically talks too much
and
rubs his nose in a lot of
different subjects in him which i don't
think he's got any any involvement in
what makes those players good leaders
like what what qualities do they have
i think leading by example because you
have people who shout
over the dressing room and
but i think the as i was saving steven
giada
not the most vocal
in the dress room but goes out on the
pitch in league by example um
so i think the the best leaders the ones
who actually walk there and and then and
do it on the pitching
and especially when
you're going through a tough moment in
the game and
they can drag you out
there's one or two where i think we
could have performed a lot better and
got into finals and if we had that
ruthless
clinical edge to us something missing i
don't know what it was but that's the
big that's the thing that always sticks
with me with united
honestly i couldn't have given any more
at any point in
any second of any day i generally feel
that it's not bragging it's not being
arrogant i genuinely gave my all